on répond à vos questions sur le
confinement sur le couvre-feu on reçoit
beaucoup de questions en voici tout de
suite avec adrian est ce que les
dentistes optométristes massothérapeute
physiothérapeute peuvent continuer de
rester ouverts jusqu'au 28 février et
après le couvre-feu demande evelyne oui
absolument
y a rien qui change en ce moment pour
les services professionnels de santé en
cabinet privé à la maison dont tout ça
on peut continuer d'y avoir accès on dit
les déplacements même après le
couvre-feu son permis sont nos besoins
de ce type de soins de santé on peut y
avoir accès et les prestataires de ce
type de soins de santé aussi peuvent se
déplacer pour les fournir à la maison si
nécessaire on suggère par contre pour
certaines consultations c'est possible
de le faire de manière virtuelle c'est
l'idéal
une pharmacie de façon virtuelle c'est
un peu ça pas le même effet à votre
retour durable marie-chantal roberge
nous demandait ce que les femmes de
ménages peuvent encore entrés dans les
maisons résidentielles des femmes de
ménage et les hommes de ménage aussi
peuvent entrer cependant il faut
s'assurer de suivre les consignes
sanitaires et hygiéniques émises par le
gouvernement
donc oui c'est toujours possible
question d'andré nantel j'aimerais
savoir si un petit concessionnaire
automobile qui va en ligne peut
continuer la vente en ligne et donc se
rendre à son bureau seulement pour
prendre possession d'un véhicule et
faire la livraison au domicile de
l'acheteur
ça c'est possible il faut comprendre que
ce type de commerce c'est un commerce
qui jugeait non essentiels non
prioritaires donc si la fermeture
jusqu'au 8 février
par contre les activités de vente en
ligne vente par téléphone cueillette et
livraison c'est toujours permis donc
c'est effectivement possible d'acheter
un véhicule et de se le faire livrer
sans entrer dans le commerce dans le
respect des consignes scène et je
mentionne kendam aujourd'hui qui nous
ont écrit sur les vtt les motoneiges et
s'appelle julie vigneault là c'est la
même chose a pas de mesures spécifiques
là pour les véhicules récréatifs c'est
la même chose
oui donc votre gestion sans bras si
matuidi
qu'en est il des cégeps et des
universités alors pour l'enseignement
supérieur le mot d'ordre demeure
toujours le même le maximum d'activités
d'enseignement à distance est toujours
de mise
les activités en classe sont permis si
la présence est absolument essentiel et
nécessaire de l'étudiant pour
l'acquisition des connaissances pour
l'évaluation les stages et laboratoires
sont maintenus également les
bibliothèques sont ouvertes uniquement
pour l'utilisation du comptoir de prêt
l'accès des espaces de travail
individuels et les activités
parascolaires et sorties éducatives sont
malheureusement pour l'instant suspendu
et nous sommes une petite entreprise qui
fait vivre créé des affaires sur le web
devant nous stopper nos activités de
fabrication et d'envois de colis de nos
clients à partir de samedi nous
personnalisons des chandails et des
t-shirts dias à 10k matic faut
comprendre que deux volets à cette
entreprise une partie manufacturier avec
la fabrication des t-shirts et l'autre
volet qui le commerce donc la vente pour
cette partie là il n'y a pas de problème
les activités peuvent se poursuivre
c'est une entreprise de toute façon qui
est déjà sur le web donc la vente de
produits existants peut déjà se
poursuivre on peut continuer d'écouler
les stocks si vous voulez et honorer les
ventes qui ont déjà été fait poursuit la
livraison des colis
la portion fabrication par contre c'est
là où c'est un peu délicat parce que je
vous rappelle que le gouvernement a
suggéré de réduire au minimum les
activités dans le minimum est
essentielle si vous voulez les activités
dans le secteur manufacturier
est ce que cette entreprise devrait
mettre la [ __ ] douce sur la
fabrication est encore certain flou qui
entoure cette portion là pour cette
entreprise en question à votre ton
gérald isabelle charest nous demandent
est ce que je peux demander à mon
employeur de ne pas travailler
je suis cuisinier durant le confinement
un employeur peut faire la demande d'un
employé peut faire la demande à son
employeur mais sauf s'il ya des
circonstances particulières l'employeur
n'a pas l'obligation d'accepter mais
s'il ya des circonstances particulières
l'employeur peut accommoder et
accompagner l'employé mais si un
problème aujourd'hui le ministre du
travail jean boulet vous suggère de
faire appel à la cnss t si vous jugez
qu'il y a abus ou non respect de votre
situation
est-ce que les palettes justice
demeurent ouverts pour des causes de
divorce et de garde d'enfants demande
pascal carrier oui et toutes sortes
d'autres causes d'ailleurs l'annoncé des
autorités gouvernementales d'hier
ça n'a pas d'impact sur les activités
judiciaires prévues au cours des
prochaines semaines on vous rappelant
toutefois que depuis plusieurs mois
depuis lé mois de pandémie on a tenté de
déplacer certaines portions des
activités des palais de justice de
manière virtuelle si vous voulez mais
les audiences qui sont prévues auront
tout de même mieux une question de
françois dionne est ce qu'il y à une
mesure d' aide financière pour les
employés qu'ils ne recevront pas de
salaire pendant le deuxième conflit en
fait il y à tout l'arsenal que nous
connaissons par coeur maintenant la pcr
eux
la led la prestation pour les proches
aidants la nouvelle prestation pour la
maladie qu'on connaît bien maintenant la
subvention salariale tout ça est
toujours en place question surprise en
terminant les grandes surfaces est
enfermé qu'advient-il si j'ai besoin
d'un réfrigérateur car le meunier vient
de rendre l'âme du jeu de brigands oui
je connais le concept du même problème
avec un lave vaisselle et moi avec un
chauffe-eau bar vous voyez alors on ne
peut pas se rendre en boutique ou en
magasin si vous voulez pour magasiner
son nouvel électro ou appareils de ce
type là c'est toujours possible
d'acheter en ligne d'acheter sur le web
ou par téléphone et de se faire livrer
tout ça ça peut être mais alors merci
beaucoup je vous signale que vous pouvez
poser d'autres questions bien sûr on va
tenter de vous répondre au cours des
prochains jours
son économie a commercial radio
canada.ca andréanne merci merci merci à
vous bonne soirée
on se retrouve demain pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh